creatures like the giant guitar fish a  type of Ray that gets its name from its  guitar shaped body can't blink instead  they retract their eyeballs pulling the  organs almost completely into their  heads now new research shows the fish  have that ability thanks to a special  eye muscle the same muscle in sharks who  don't retract their eyes is smaller and  attaches the eye to the middle of the  eye socket  but in Guitar fish the muscle is larger  and longer it connects the eye to the  underside of the skull giving the  creatures an increased range of motion  that helps the animal protect their eyes  like our eyelids do when we blink just  don't challenge these tropical fish to a  staring contest you're sure to lose  [Music]